ya hemos aprendido bastante acerca de
derivadas así es que vamos a aplicarlas
en algo que yo pienso espero que sea
sumamente útil empecemos revisando la
regla de la cadena
así es que para empezar supongamos que
tenemos la función f
de x y voice una anotación que puede ser
extraña para ti entonces lo que voy a
hacer aquí es voy a tomar la derivada
con respecto a x
y agarrado otro color eso lo hago
bastante frecuentemente toma otro color
entonces la derivada de f deje de x es
igual
razón en que f cambia con respecto a g
esto es
efe
de g
x
la tasa de cambio de g con respecto a x
de g
en de equis y aquí podrías decir oye sal
eso es totalmente extraño para mí y una
de dos puedes pensarlo en la forma como
lo he planteado o bien lo puedo escribir
de la manera tradicional como hemos
escrito la regla de la cadena este es en
realidad la tradicional pero bueno lo va
a poner en la manera como te lo enseñado
y como te lo enseñado que es la razón de
cambio de f con respecto a g la razón de
cambio desde con respecto a qué es efe
prima
x
la razón de cambio de eje con respecto a
x que es prima de x espero que esto haga
sentido que estas son las anotaciones
distintas para la regla de la cadena
aquí tenemos la notación desarrollada
por ley venís aquí abajo la desarrollada
por alguna otra persona y esta anotación
ha sentido desde el punto de vista de
fracciones de g&d que se cancelan aquí
para obtener la tasa de cambio de f con
respecto a x con esto en mente hagamos
algo entretenido supongamos que tenemos
uno de esos vasos de sus bonitos que
usamos para tomar agua
dibujemos el cono aquí tenemos ese cono
aquí tenemos ese cono como los que están
junto a los enfriadores y supongamos que
en cualquier punto la razón la relación
que se tiene entre la altura y el radio
de ese cono aquí tenemos la altura h la
razón del radio la altura es de 1 a 2
por lo que si la altura es h el radio es
medio h y este es en cualquier punto
como sabes es un cono de estas líneas
son fijas así es que esta relación es
para cualquier punto en el cono
así es que para analizar el problema
quizás esto no lo has visto
anteriormente pero nos va a ser útil por
lo que supongamos que llenamos de agua
este cono supongamos que le ponemos agua
hasta una altura h vamos a dibujar el
nivel del agua aquí tenemos el nivel del
agua en el cono
llamen si me sobre todo lo escrito
anteriormente pero bueno esta es la
altura del agua entonces suponiendo que
está a una altura h cuál es el volumen
de agua que tenemos en el corte cuál es
el volumen de agua que tenemos en el
cono cuando está a una altura de h
centímetros por ejemplo el volumen de un
icono quizás no lo sabes y esto tendrá
oportunidad de mostrarte lo cuando
veamos integración sólidos de revolución
por integración pero bueno el volumen de
un cono está dado por b igual a un
tercio de base por la altura y la base
aquí es este círculo que forma la
superficie del agua entonces que tenemos
que el volumen el volumen es igual a un
tercio de la base y cuál es la base la
base esto es un círculo entonces sería
tipo radio al cuadrado y aquí estamos
usando geometría plana entonces tenemos
aquí que el volumen sería
un tercio de pi por radio al cuadrado
por altura en este ejemplo dijimos que
el radio es un medio de la altura
entonces sería un tercio de pi por un
medio de h al cuadrado por h no hemos
hecho aún nada de cálculos simplemente
algo de geometría que no es tan
complicado tan sólo un poco de talacha
así es que si simplificamos esta
expresión tenemos que volumen es igual a
un tercio de pi y aquí tenemos un medio
de h cuadrada un medio de h al cuadrado
sería un cuarto de h cuadrada un cuarto
por un tercio sería un doceavo de pi por
el 4 por h h
kubica muy interesante ahora hagamos
algo de cálculo algo que te va a
disparar la mente supongamos que
empezamos a llenar de agua supongamos
que empezamos a llenar de agua este cono
entonces aquí tenemos agua que está
entrando al cono y supongamos que
estamos llenando de agua a una taza de
un centímetro cúbico por segundo y en
ocasiones esto se maneja en el sistema
métrico como un cc o su equivalente un
mililitro pero yo voy a quedar con
centímetro cúbico por segundo pues vamos
a trabajar con centímetros en múltiples
dimensiones así es que suponemos que
está entrando una tasa un centímetro
cúbico por segundo y lo que yo quiero
saber y esto es una pregunta muy
interesante lo que yo quiero saber es
qué tan rápido está cambiando el nivel
del agua qué tan rápido está cambiando
la altura del nivel del agua cuando ésta
se encuentra a una altura de dos cuando
el agua se encuentra a una altura de dos
centímetros
cómo hacemos esto aquí tenemos algo
estático si tenemos una altura dada
podemos obtener el volumen pero si
tomamos la razón de cambio con respecto
al tiempo a ambos lados obtendremos algo
interesante
tomemos entonces la derivada con
respecto al tiempo a ambos lados cual la
derivada con respecto al tiempo del lado
izquierdo ahí va a db con respecto al
tiempo es simplemente debe
dt y esto va a ser igual a la derivada
con respecto al tiempo de este lado de
la ecuación y cuál es la derivada de
este lado con respecto al tiempo bueno
la derivada de esta expresión con
respecto al tiempo va a ser igual
aquí tenemos b en función de h de
acuerdo entonces la derivada con
respecto al tiempo de hacer qué tan
rápido cambia de con respecto a h deben
de h por qué tan rápido cambia h con
respecto a t de hdt es la regla de la
cadena que tenemos acá arriba si te
fijas bien aquí estamos aplicando
también la regla cadena aunque puede ser
un poco confuso porque aquí no tenemos
te aquí tenemos h
a decir verdad esta h depende del tiempo
así es que con esto en mente resolvamos
está derivada la arribada de b con
respecto a t esto es igual deben de t es
la derivada de b con respecto a h
la diva de b con respecto a que esto es
fácil pues aquí tenemos h cúbica h
cúbica el exponente pasa multiplicando
sería 3-2 ya vos 32 ya vos por pi es
simplemente pi sobre 4
por h cuadrada eso es esta parte
en esta parte de aquí déjame poner otro
color dejamos el otro color en esta
parte de aquí voy a describirlo con el
otro color de hdt por dh en dt tú
podrías decir sal que tanto has hecho
bueno la tasa con la que el volumen
cambia con respecto al tiempo es igual a
pi cuartos de h cuadrada por la tasa con
la que la altura cambia con respecto al
tiempo se ha resuelto así el problema
déjame ser un poco de espacio va a ser
un espacio por acá nos lo va a poner
aquí abajo que sabemos sabemos que la
tasa con que cambio el volumen con
respecto al tiempo deben de t es igual a
un centímetro cúbico por segundo así
tenemos que deben de t es igual a 1
vamos a no poner las unidades para no
complicar la ecuación 1 que es igual
y cuartos aquí tenemos depende de la
tasa a la cual está cambiando el volumen
con respecto al tiempo que es igual a 1
por que es igual a pi cuartos por la
altura del ebb al cuadrado pero que
sabemos de la altura la altura es igual
a 22 elevado al cuadrado es igual a 4
esto lo que conocemos h igualados
entonces en ese momento h es igual a 2
elevó al cuadro es igual a 4 por dh en
de t esto se simplifica y nos queda uno
es igual a pi por dh en dt resolvemos
para de hdt déjame hacerlo aquí arriba
espero que no te confundas entonces la
tasa a la que cambia la altura con
respecto al tiempo es igual a 1 sobre pi
esto es fascinante 1 sobre pi
centímetros por segundo podemos
aproximar ese número como punto 3 y algo
punto 3 y piquito y esa es la tasa a la
que sube el nivel del agua punto 3
centímetros por segundo cuando estamos
agregando agua para cambiar el volumen
de ese cono a razón de un centímetro
cúbico por segundo quizá esté confundido
y puedes volver a revisar este vídeo
más vídeos de razones de cambio que
tienden a confundir pero al final de
cuentas se hacen sencillos conforme los
vas practicando nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo